bonjour adel merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en direct ce
matin sur rtl france j'ai envie de dire
tout d'abord comment allez vous après
ces longues journées passées à au
terminal de roissy resta on essaie de
rester avec le moral est haché même pas
si on peut parler de vivre juste passer
des journées et c'est resté solidaire
justement comment est ce que vous faites
pour dormir pour vous nourrir pour vous
l'avez comment ça se passe très
concrètement les journées que que vous
êtes en train de vivre
il ya des gens qui a dit dans le sol il
ya des gens qui siègent l'aéroport et
des gens qui vaudra qui y est chaque
ensemble à son truc et est vraiment très
délicat
moi je suis encore jeune mais il ya des
gens il dit il ya une personne qui tient
cancer la prostate il personne qui qui
est juste revenu de l'hôpital de paris à
l'aise il ya deux de ces personnes là
qui à 78 ans qui est fatigué ah c'est
pas facile pour ces gens là aussi qu'on
comprenne bien votre situation de
blocage vous arriviez d'angleterre
l'algérie a décidé presque
concomitamment de fermer ses frontières
et le problème c'est que vous n'aviez
pas été prévenus c'est ça de cette
fermeture voilà c'est pas une question
de fermeture aux frontières c'est tout à
fait faux parce qu'on était là le 26
février les frontières officiellement et
c'était fermé le 1er mars les passagers
ici les trois passagers d'utiliser des
enfants
ils ont tous a eu délai les
autorisations de la part du consulat
algérien à londres et on a tous des
billets à
air algérie a ti précise des billets de
rapatriement est on a un test pcr qu'on
a fait le 25 février
alors on était en avait tous les droits
dont parquet et voilà s'ils disent
qu'ils ans qu'ils ont annulé nous piller
ou quoi que ce soit je pense pas déjà
qu'ils ont fait ça ils ont fait ça très
tardivement et à aider et un
personnellement il ya des gens qu'ils en
rien reçu il ya des personnages est déjà
acquis qu'ils savent pas manipuler
l'ordinateur qui savent pas manipuler la
paralysie mais le quoi que ce soit et
sont venus y sont parquées normalement
possible à londres ils sont venus ici et
là variés laurenti que prendre il faut
allez vous revenir en angleterre pour
certaines personnes c'était pas possible
on a avec nous quand une personne qui
est inquiet son papier qui a demandé au
consulat algérien à vendre de lui donner
un laissez-passer et là maintenant il
est bloqué au milieu on a une en à une
personne qui puisse à touristique et un
dès lors qu'elle est sortie d'angleterre
elle peut plus revenir parce que c'est
là un visa touristique et longue lutte
erna n'accepte plus les touristes là bas
a jusqu'au 17 mai ah si je suis un couac
et voilà si c'est vraiment délicate
on a parlé à plusieurs reprises avec les
autres dvd
la direction d'air algérie le
responsable d'air algérie séjour non non
on entre là français a levé en ce moment
tous les jours tous les jours on est en
train de voir bébé des vols d'air france
qui partent vite avancé ils partent à 22
20 passagers algériens et à des
étrangers aussi
on a pris des on a pris des vidéos et à
ses journalistes
ces autorisations du nikon ministère
l'intérieur algérien qui leur demander
des autorisations de rentrer au pays
pour moi voilà c'est on veut juste avoir
les mêmes motorisations de ces gens là
parce que il faut le redire c'est pas de
notre faute quoi quand on est dans cette
situation
pas du tout parce que précisons le vous
avez tous des passeports algériens
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous demandez
concrètement d'ailleurs votre avocat n'a
pas pu accéder à avoir dans ce terminal
voilà je pense que ils ont fait une
demande ça a été refusé alors ils font
un autre court et un j'espère qu'ils
vont qui vont rentrer ici maintenant la
sphère elle est dans la justice ans est
bon et notre nom notre principal avec
moi on va dire à personne qu'on attaque
aujourd'hui c'est air algérie parce que
je pense qu'ils ont tort qu'ils ont pas
fait les choses à raymond correctement
la france elle vous a apporté assistance
jusque là ou pas sincèrement un mois se
tirer plus que les cas la communauté
algérienne qui est tunisienne marocaine
et à éliminer votre qui nous ont l'air
plus aidé iliad et la dpi la femme en
direct la direction de l'aéroport ils
nous ont aidés mais je pense à mon avis
ça a été c'était part d'ibm en maille et
nous voilà
du 26 au 28 on a acheté de la nourriture
et à et de notre poche carrément l
algérie ils ont dit dans le communiqué
qui nous ont donné à manger pendant
quinze jours et c'est totalement faux et
nous ont donné du 1er mars
oui mars et on a des preuves avec des
emails qui est qui ils nous ont dit
carrément qui est plus parce que
apparemment c'est nous qui voulons
rester ici et après ça a des pays du 21
au 22 mai ils ont commencé à nous donner
de la nourriture et à
donner accès aux merci beaucoup à dell
pour votre témoignage ce matin vous
souhaite évidemment de pouvoir aller là
où vous le souhaitez en tout cas
rapidement merci pour votre témoignage